hi i'm danny devito this is the wired
incomplete video
what
this is the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
part two
do i remember part one no
first card what was danny devito's first
job i was like 14 years old little kid
got my working papers in asbury park i
put the little kids on the on the kiddie
rides you know like the rides went
around in circles like a car or a boat
or a
fire engine they were little they gave
me the ticket and i pushed the button
and then we go around slow on a
boardwalk and i say ring the bell ring
the bell and the fire engine
steer the wheels to the wheel you know
what i mean
and then the ride would end and i take
them off that was my first job 14 years
old what was danny devito big break i
was in cuckoo's nest but everybody
thought i was an inmate but taxi was my
big break that was the big one 1978
before many of you were born you can
throw those papers away these papers
okay they're gone okay what is danny
devito's accent jersey
very jersey south jersey i was born in
it's kind of like a philly baltimore
thingy but it's jersey
and it's a little new york my father was
from brooklyn so i got a little bit of
that philly is very what i do on so he's
sunny is a little bit more we
we exaggerate it is it taylor ham or
pork roll oh taylor ham taylor ham on a
hard roll with some mustard in a
and lettuce oh man
i could i want one now what characters
does danny devito voice well right now
i'm in little demon and i voice
satan a very nice guy
okay well to some what is danny devito
like in real life hmm you tell me i
don't know you're looking at me are you
looking at me are you looking at me
what am i like in real life
i don't know
next board here we go
well this is going well
is danny devito
a method actor well i have my method
yes
did i ever work at the actors studio i
did a couple pla couple things there
once i subscribed to like the
constantine stanislavski precips
but i do like stella adler i do like lee
strasberg but it's different you know
you take a little bit from each one is
danny devito
a grandfather no
not yet
i love kids and i can't wait
because i am gonna
take them
okay let's see
is danny devito
related to arnold yes
arnold schwarzenegger he's my little
brother is that who you meant oh arnold
couldn't fit it on the line
schwarzenegger right would've gave it
away arnold palmer we get along really
well he is
the
really cool and we have a lot of fun and
we can't wait to work together again
is danny devito
from philadelphia now i'm from new
jersey asbury park new jersey which is
where bruce springsteen claims to be
from but he's actually from freehold but
when he was doing his first album he
wanted to call he couldn't call it
greetings from freehold so he called the
greetings from asbury park
i love bruce is danny devito a good
penguin well you got to tell me am i the
good penguin come on
there's no contest so i remember like it
was yesterday i used to get up five
o'clock in the morning to go uh
v kneel master
full
she was a incredible makeup artist she
would stand there with like a pot of
glue the pot of glue
the key thing is it had to be cold
in order to work and she would come over
and she would take this big fat brush
freezing cold glue
and put it right
right there
then she put the nose on and once she
did that
and patted it down and powdered it
piece of cake i was in for the whole day
didn't bother me didn't even know i had
it on
i acted like the penguin then as soon as
the nose went on so
beware
how did danny devito
become an actor my sister had a beauty
parlor and she gave me a job in the
beauty parlor can you imagine me in the
beauty pal she sent me to school i went
to become a hairdresser and then she
wanted to get into makeup
so she sent me to new york to go to
makeup school aha the only thing is at
that makeup school there was also a
drama department i took a class
and i got hooked on it i just
didn't want to do anything else
except
become an actor
how old was danny devito when a couple
minutes ago no now then 20. how old was
danny rito how old was dannyville why
are you just
sticking to the old thing okay i'm old
all right wait how was danny devito
stoned
baby
you don't want to see me stoned oh i
pulled him wrong oh i didn't pull the
thing the tab how how was danny devito
in taxi i had been around 30
something 34
33 34 years old i would bet how old is
danny devito and romancing the stone
tiny bit older i did taxi for five years
then i did romancing the stone and
romance with stone is like in the 80s so
you figure it out google me will danny
devito will danny devito be in the
live-action hercules i am the
live-action hercules what are you
talking about philip tatis if they don't
put me in that they don't have a hair on
their ass
okay
next call next card
and thank god there's two cameras you
can always cut you know what i'm saying
when did danny devito join sunny i'm not
sure of the year but i think it was 16
years ago maybe 17 years ago why did
danny devito make matilda
well my kids brought the book to me they
as they were reading it the chapter book
written by roald dahl
and i i just loved it but i said if i'm
gonna make another movie i gotta make
matilda because it was for every kid i
imagine i thought it was and it
certainly has been i think everybody
really dug it where is danny devito's
what my hollywood star i got great real
estate if you go to grounds chinese
theater or
the chinese theater as they call it and
go across the street
there's my star i don't know who i'm
next to because i'm a self-centered
actor
you know how many actors it takes to
screw in a light bulb one he holds on to
the light bulb and the world revolves
around him where
to buy
danny devito's limoncello i'm not sure
where you can get it now i mean i i had
a lot of fun making it
doing it and
i i still think i have a couple bottles
around my house did danny devito own a
restaurant i'd lent my name to a
restaurant in miami with the hopes that
it would be successful
and uh it became a lot of
it was a headache and so i took my name
off the restaurant and that was that i
had enough of that
was danny devito on snl yes i was many
times i hosted it five times i have a
clock that they gave me to prove it i am
a member of the five-timer club and uh
we had a great time and i loved it was
danny devito in friends yes i played uh
officer good body and friends and i
stripped
kind of
and i had a great time doing that was
danny devito in who
harry potter no no no i wasn't in harry
potter i don't think that was uh richard
griffiths was in harry potter
if you ever see with nail and i he was
in that too oh richard really terrific
actor was danny devito in the seinfeld
no
i was never in seinfeld were you
initially going to be in seinfeld no
i wasn't i wasn't ever going to be in
seinfeld i think that jason alexander
and i
have a sam a similar look that may be
why people think
you know i was in that
okay here we go let's see last one danny
devito danny devito
and aubry plaza yes
is so much fun she plays my
wife
the woman i love
in little demon and she is the mother of
my demon child and she's a great actress
and she's so much fun to work with danny
devito body pillow well you can you know
you probably could find one i think you
can find a body pillow i have made the
shape of danny devito if you want to
hang out with it you have my blessing
any you know production company jersey
jersey films made lots of movies a lot
of the movies that i've directed and
things that i've been in plus pulp
fiction and aaron brockovich and lots of
things matilda and we now uh
co-producing a show
on fxx called little demon this is my
first animation and it was really really
fun it's very very interesting learning
it took us a few years to do it i've
been in animated movies before as an
actor and has voiced them but i've never
produced one and no lucy and i and jake
my son who's
also a part of little demon with aubry
and also this guy dan harmon who does
that rick and morty show he's also a
producer danny devito
when he was young oh yes when i was
young
what was i doing i was just hanging out
you know living in jersey eating pizza
subs
sandwiches
danny devito urologist oh yeah i did the
thing with mikey d i played michael
douglas's
um
urologist in uh the
kaminsky
method mikey and i go back really long
time and you heard about the lawsuit
right i played his you know proctologist
and uh
we're in the middle of a lawsuit now
because
i'm trying to get my watch back
terrible joke
okay
anyway
the questions are great and i'm really
especially when you asked me about
little demon is on fxx it's a 10 o'clock
show so keep the little ones away thanks
for watching
peace